Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and during my
Birds of Prey review I asked you to submit
all of your questions about the rest of the
season.
Everyone is wondering about Ravager, which
character is going to die and who’s going
to be the next big villain after Slade.
So because there’s so much awesome to talk
about, let’s just get right in it.
Like usual I picked 10 of your questions with
one bonus one.
Careful for spoilers from the episode if you’re
not caught up.
Here we go Question 1 - Mr Alucard Rules asks
what do you think the episode city of blood
will be about?
It sounds like they’re teasing that Brother
Blood is going to spread the serum around
the city and turn a bunch of citizens into
‘brothers’.
Since it’s so much farther ahead, it’s
also possible that he could win the Mayoral
election.
Brother Blood hasn’t been featured much
since Slade’s story came to the forefront.
And I don’t really mind.
I just haven’t felt like he’s been a threat
to Team Arrow so far.
He’s like Slade’s squire.
The underling that runs to get him coffee
and moisturizer for his empty eye socket.
So City of Blood will just be his chance to
come roaring back into the story.
Episode 18, Deathstroke, is Slade heavy.
So City of Blood will just be Brother Blood’s
version of that.
We might even get some comic book style flashbacks.
Question 2 - Ijaz Sultan asks Hey Charlie
you know the scene where Roy gets shots in
the right hand do you think that thats a sort
of Arsenal nod/tease?﻿
That’s an interesting idea, I hadn’t thought
of it that way but it’s totally possible.
For those that don’t know, there was a comic
book story where Roy got his arm chopped off.
That version of the character wasn’t enhanced
by mirakuru, not that mirakuru could help
you grow one back.
But it’s possible that it was a teaser that
in a future episode, Roy will sustain an injury
that he can’t heal from, either physical
or emotional.
They spent a couple moments of dialogue on
Roy telling Oliver that the wound was nothing,
it just seemed like they were setting him
up to eventually get a super serious injury.
Like arm chopped off serious.
Question 3 - Sree Ram asks Did we just see
summer glau's character fight oliver?
does that mean she works with slade?
this may seem farfetch'd but could she be
slade's daughter?﻿
My initial thought was yes, but I had to take
a screengrab to double check.
In all of the frames, her arm was covering
up her face a little.
But she seems like she has Summer Glau’s
build, tall, thin and punchy.
If you didn’t know, before she starred in
Firefly for Joss Whedon, she was a professional
dancer, mostly Ballet.
So she was super flexible.
Which is why it was easy for her to do all
those beautiful dancy fight moves.
The conceit is that Isobel has been working
with Slade this whole time to take control
of Queen Industries.
In one of my videos last year I predicted
that Isobel would be connected to HIVE and
they would be the evil financial arm of Slade’s
plan.
In the comics, Deathstroke has heavy ties
to HIVE, but we don’t know what his connection
to them on Arrow is yet.
Hopefully episode 18 will give us that information.
How else could the pay for Brother Blood’s
run for Mayor, electoral campaigns are super
expensive.
To give you an idea, during the last presidential
campaign, both Obama and Mitt Romney spent
an estimated 7 Billion Dollars combined.
Most of that on their television ads and marketing.
That’s why I think Slade is connected to
HIVE and he’s using them to fund Brother
Blood.
And Isobel will turn out to be working for
them.
HIVE is a really big deal, so I’ll talk
more about them in a sec.
The real story, is that if Isobel is working
with Slade, is she Ravager.
I think it’s more likely that they’ll
change that character a little so she will
be Ravager, but her backstory will change
a little.
I’m hoping that they’ll make her Slade’s
daughter.
Since some of her backstory already lines
up with Ravagers.
Why else would the cast Summer Glau, someone
who doesn’t necessarily look like a threat,
but has played martial artists and she was
even a freaking terminator.
Of course Deathstroke The Terminator’s daughter
would be a Terminator.
That would make a great title for a season
3 episode “The Terminator’s Daughter”.
Question 4 - Michael Paulsen (no avatar) asks
Do you think thea will figure out Roys or
Olivers secret identities during her rescue
mission?
Yes, definitely.
I think she’ll find out that they’re involved
in this war with Slade and then they’ll
tell her the full story.
Here’s an interesting thought.
Have you ever heard that a little bit of information
can be really dangerous?
As opposed to having all of the information.
I think that Thea is going to pull a similar
move to Laurel last week and let the darkness
in after getting a little bit of information
about Oliver and Roy.
If she’s not the one to die this season
then I do expect her to become the next unofficial
member of team arrow.
A lot of people are wondering if she’s ever
going to become the Mia Dearden.
Just because Moira’s maiden name was Dearden.
Not to be super morbid, but I hope Moira becomes
a casualty of the war and it inspires Thea
to join the new family business.
Question 5 - Nick Wong asks Based on this
episode, it doesn't look like it was the huntress
that knocked diggle out in the promise.
Who do you think it is now?﻿
Since Huntress didn’t end up being as big
a character as I’d hoped, I think the next
best guess is Isobel or Ravager.
Which based on that teaser for episode 18
seems more realistic.
We haven’t seen Summer Glau in so long and
see her throw down with Oliver makes me feel
like the ‘allies’ Slade said he had included
Isobel.
I saw a lot of you guys suggesting it might
be Nyssa, but I feel like if it were her,
they would have shown her face in the episode.
It’s totally possible that the actress wasn’t
available the day they filmed that Diggle
scene, but for now.
Based on what we’ve seen, my best guess
is Isobel.
Question 6 - DarkfireKurai asks With Officer
Lance teaming up with The Arrow, do you think
its only a matter of time until he gets in-trouble
for doing so?﻿
Definitely, he totally hit that other officer
in the head to protect Oliver.
The big teaser for Man Under The Hood, episode
19 is people learning Oliver’s identity.
And remember, Brother Blood did have people
inside the police department.
The minion masquerading as Brother Blood was
killed, but that doesn’t mean that Quentin
has the full support of the department.
The way I see his character now is a lot like
Jim Gordon during Batman year one.
He was a rookie cop and had to clear out corruption
in the department, before eventually becoming
Commissioner Gordon.
I think Quentin is on the same path.
Hopefully they won’t kill him off this season.
Just to be clear, I don’t think he’ll
die.
They’ve invested way too much time in that
character.
The Batman Gordon parallels are just too awesome
to drop those storylines.
And Paul Blackthorne is a great actor, you
don’t just get rid of your “A” team.
Which is why they totally didn’t officially
kill John Barrowman.
He’s just way too awesome.
Plus there’s the whole Captain Jack immortality
thing going on.
Question 7 - The PTMD3 asks Do you think there's
gonna be a Bane-Batman repair (Batman takes
a bullet for Bane so Bane saves him with Lazarus
Pit) between Slade and Oliver?
They’ve been posting images of upcoming
episodes where Oliver just gets madder and
madder, so they want us to think he’s going
to try and kill Slade.
Especially now with him capturing Thea.
But I don’t think it’s going to go down
like that.
What does he say during the intro for every
single episode.
“I can’t be the killer I once was.”
Implying that he’ll show Slade mercy.
I don’t think it will be a near death thing.
They’re not going to dose Oliver with Mirakuru
and I don’t think we’ll get a Lazarus
Pit this season.
But I do think Slade will show him mercy or
help him out.
It all depends on if the Ra’s Al Ghul cameo
works out.
Marc Guggenheim and Manu Bennett teased it.
They said it depends on a lot of things behind
the scenes working out, so it’s still unconfirmed.
Question 8 - Loriandanna asks Do you think
that Slade is just in a Mirakuru Rage or is
there a little bit more of him that has turned
evil?
That’s what we’re going to learn about
in Episode 18.
We’ll learn what the Mirakuru has done to
his brain for the last 6 years.
Mostly made him crazy.
It is a lot like the psychosis people experience
after using the Lazarus Pit.
They just go insane temporarily.
I think that madness will be Slade’s cross
to bear for the rest of his long-mirakuru-enhanced
life.
And it will just be like a wound that never
heals.
Like Wolverine’s claws hurting every time
he pops them out.
Question 9 - Radbot Films asks Did you notice
all the Red in the Episode?
Yes, everyone took it to mean Red Arrow and
Red Hood teasers.
I think it’s mostly foreshadowing Roy’s
Arsenal persona.
And Brother Blood’s plan to convert the
city.
Blood Red.
There was also the Nightwing symbol in an
earlier episode.
It’s just easy ways for them to include
references to characters without creating
the burden of casting actors or finding ways
to fit more intellectual property into a story
than is necessary.
Most of the time it’s more of a wink.
Like Gail Street and Simone Avenue during
Birds of Prey.
Just a really quick shot here and there.
I try not to read too much into it, but it
does make it fun to re-watch episodes to look
for easter eggs.
Question 10 - Crystal X asks Who would be
the most unexpected character to die?﻿
Most unexpected death would of course be Oliver.
The only way that would work would be if they
featured the Lazarus Pit, or Arrow’s version
of the Lazarus Pit.
Which I don’t think is the mirakuru.
It can’t bring someone dead back to life.
And most of the time, it straight up kills
people.
Of the people that might actually die, the
most unexpected I think would be Thea.
Usually you cull the weak ones out of the
herd.
And Moira feels like she’s just been blowing
smoke.
Thea on the other hand could totally become
a superhero in her own right given the right
story arc.
Which might be what’s happening right now.
So if she did die, it would be a huge surprise.
Bonus Question 1 - Pepper Jim asks How do
you think that the Deathstroke story arc will
end?
With Oliver defeating Slade and bringing him
back to sanity.
Then them parting ways, not as friends.
But as brothers that just hate each other.
They really pushed the idea of them as ‘brothers’
during The Promise.
I think that theme is going to come back around
before the finale.
I don’t think Slade will die, they didn’t
kill Merlin.
And who else here wants a Deathstroke spinoff,
or a Teen Titans spinoff that Slade is a huge
part of.
They wouldn’t be able to do any of that
if he were dead.
Bonus Question 2 - PG Eire asks If Oliver
defeats Slade, who will be the season 3 villain?
So based on my last answer, yes of course
Oliver will defeat Slade.
And I don’t think anyone expects him to
be the biggest villain again next season.
So how do you top Deathstroke?
There’s a couple of possibilities.
One, it could be the organization HIVE.
Who’s in charge of that at the moment?
No Idea.
But the organization itself would be the villain.
The other possibility is a Justice League
villain like Prometheus or Amazo, they’ve
been showing that Amazo boat so freaking much
this season.
I’m not expecting any cosmic villains or
outright super powered villains.
At least supervillains who don’t use technology
to enhance their abilities.
The Flash show is going to be the first to
tackle real super powers.
Really I think Prometheus would be a good
fit, plus there’s the whole Cry for Justice
storyline where he chops off Roy’s arm.
Not that I think arrow would ever make Colton
Haynes limp around with one arm for the rest
of the series.
That would just be cruel.
So thank you so much for submitting your questions.
This was a ton of fun, like I said.
Next week is a deep dive into Deathstroke.
Be sure to subscribe to get my video.
Just think about how awesome it’s going
to be.
In the meantime, check out my review of the
episode here and click here to learn more
about the Avengers 2 Villains.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!